Hello, and welcome to CS 7637,
knowledge-based artificial
intelligence/cognitive systems.
My name is Ashok Goel.
>> My name is David Joyner.
>> I'm a Professor of Computer Science
and Cognitive Science at Georgia Tech.
I've been teaching knowledge-based
AI for about 25 years.
I've been doing research
in this area for about 30.
My personal passion is for
computational creatively.
Breathing air agents that human like and
creative in their own right.
>> I'm, of course,
developer with Udacity and
I'm also finishing up my own PhD
dissertation here at Georgia Tech
with Ashok as my advisor.
My personal passion is for education and
especially for using modern technology
to deliver individualized
personal educational experiences.
It would be very difficult
in very large classrooms.
As we'll see AI is not just
the subject of this course, but
it's all a tool we're using
to teach this course.
>> We had a lot of fun
putting this course together.
We hope you enjoy it as well.
We think of this course
as an experiment as well.
We want to understand how students
learn in online classrooms.
So if you have any feedback
please share it with us.